Speaker 1: I don't know how many of you are
going to believe this or not, but it is very
true.
There is talk of Hillary Clinton 2024.
Let let that sink in.
They are talking about Hillary 2024 again,
and what we are seeing is that so far in the
midst of what's going on with COVID and an
understandable frustration with lack of more
tangible accomplishments among many, Joe Biden
and Kamala Harris are being increasingly seen
as uninspiring, unexciting and vulnerable
in 2024.
And I've said before this part, I agree with
completely.
I've said in 2024, if Trump's the nominee
or if DeSantis is the nominee, I don't feel
super confident about Biden versus either
of them.
And if Biden says I'm not running for reelection,
but here's Kamala, and Kamala is basically
awarded the Democratic nomination, I also
don't feel very confident about that.
Some who share my concerns are saying, Let's
look at bringing Hillary back.
The idea being in hindsight, so this is this
is the case some are making.
I'm not making this case.
The case some are making is, listen, the American
public now knows what a mistake it was to
choose Trump over Hillary.
So what better way to put a Democrat back
in the White House than to say now do the
right thing with Hillary?
I think this is potentially disastrous.
There is a very interesting article in The
Wall Street Journal, which full disclosure
The Wall Street Journal is part of News Corp,
Fox News, etc.
This is an op ed by Doug Schoen and Andrew
Stein, and it's called Hillary Clinton's 2024
election comeback.
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris have become unpopular.
It may be time for a change candidate.
Now you can agree with part of this and not
all of it.
Let me tell you what I mean by that.
Joe Biden and Kamala Harris have become unpopular
when you actually look at their average of
approval ratings.
Joe Biden's actually doing OK.
There is no mathematical case that Joe Biden
is really unpopular, as you can see.
Biden's approval came down significantly in
late July through September and into October,
but since then it's basically basically been
steady within one point and it is not unusually
low.
If you look as FiveThirtyEight allows you
to do.
If you look at how Biden compares with past
presidents, Biden is more popular by about
six points at this point in time than Trump
was during his presidency.
And he's sort of close to others.
I mean, you know, I think the exception, certainly
with George W. Bush, at this point in time,
Bush had the he was buoyed in his approval
by by nine 11.
Joe Biden is less popular right now than Obama,
Clinton, George H.W.
Bush, Reagan, Nixon.
Ford is very, very close and less popular
than Jimmy Carter.
That's true.
But compared to Trump, he's actually doing
better.
So for me, the approval rating right now is
not really the signal about whether Joe Biden
can or cannot win in 2024.
But what this is a signal about is that there
is no question that it's hard to look at the
Biden-Harris administration and be excited
now.
To some degree, they were handed a very difficult
situation when it comes to the pandemic.
But this is less about popularity today, per
se.
It's more about the vision for what do things
look like after the midterms?
What is it exactly that this administration
is going to stand for or accomplish?
And to some degree, the reason people are
talking about Hillary is that there aren't
many inspiring figures in the Democratic Party
that people are excited about for 2024.
I know that there is.
Let me go through some of the contingents.
There is a contingent that says it's Bernie's
time.
I believe Bernie's time has come and gone.
I don't think a third run from Bernie is going
to be what inspires the Democratic Party to
come together and to defeat whoever is the
Republican in 2024.
I just don't see it, and I know some of you
disagree with me.
I love Bernie.
I just don't think Bernie at whatever age
he will be.
Bernie Sanders age Bernie is 80.
So he would be, what, 80, 82, 82, 83, 83,
84 when he would become.
I just don't see it.
And you can apply the same thing to Biden,
and that's fine.
I wouldn't disagree with you.
I think that there's an issue with Biden's
age as well.
I don't think that that's what it is.
There's another side that says there's no
one more exciting than AOC.
I think it would be really tough in 24 for
AOC to run for president.
Would she even be old enough?
That's another question.
When will AOC be old enough to run for president?
She turns 35 a few weeks before Election Day,
OK, so she may be eligible.
I have a really hard time imagining that AOC
is going to win the presidency in 2024, despite
a lot of people being very excited about her.
So then you end up with people saying stuff,
Well, what about Warren Boudette, judge?
And it makes a lot of progressives cringe,
even though when you look on paper, Warren's
one of the few people proposing a wealth tax,
something very popular with the progressives.
Boudette judge is one of the few guys who
can actually consistently out rhetoric, whoever
it is he's talking about, Fox News host whatever,
but it doesn't feel like it's going to really
inspire the widest swath of the Democratic
Party.
So I get why people are again saying, I don't
know.
Maybe Hillary again, she's younger than some
of these other people, but it strikes me as
potentially disastrous.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at Packman.
We'll take a break and be back right after
this.